i feel like the pressure is just
something that you worked for
pressure gonna come with you being one
of the top players with you being what
you work to be
you can use it as fuel or you can use it
as negative energy and let it be a
downfall
[Applause]
i wonder how people feel if you ask
lebron about pressure
he went to the league at 18 years old
and everybody's saying he wasn't going
to be this he wasn't going to be that
it's all on you it's all mental really
javari smith
smith set up three
[Applause]
[Music]
12 27 in the afternoon when he was born
play that normal cash flow frequently
it was every dad dreamed about
holding his own son daughter kid
that's why i really wanted you know
forced upon me i really loved basketball
as a kid like i used to be
watching the games
playing 2k like anything just basketball
was just me
just come from athletic family so it was
like
it was kind of natural
oh this is what you want to do you want
to go home okay let me show you what's
going on with this like okay this is how
you do this and he started it's a
everyday thing now dad wake me up
five years old like before the bus come
put the lights in the driveway turn the
garage light on now we got light
[Music]
it kind of like fell naturally my
brother playing it my dad play it it's
like it's just in my household so it's
like it's hard to say
no to it really
so i used to come home from these
overseas jobs
you go for five months so you ain't
laying eyes on your kids
my last long stint was i ran
the boy grew so much his brother grew so
much so you know they picked me up from
the airport you know i teared up
it was just hard for him to keep leaving
for many months and then coming back and
seeing me growing up and stuff like that
he just didn't really want to miss out
on that too much more so
i wanted to be a daddy
more than i wanted to go hoop at that
point
he could have played basketball as long
as he wanted to but he knew
as i got older he just wanted to be in
my life because you know he grew up
without a father figure
it was just his focal point to just be
in my life and just give me that
guidance to just be there with me along
the way so
i just owe him to give him my all he
stopped playing basketball for me so why
wouldn't i just go out there and give
him my all maximize my potential and
just
go as far as i want to with basketball
so
favorite thing in the room
i got a lot of
i got a lot of high school stuff
but this is my mcdonald's all of this is
kind of like
made me kind of sad cause you know i
didn't get to play none of that because
the covert and stuff like that but this
is the mcdonald's all-american thing
this is the jordan brand classic but
they canceled them due to covert and
stuff like that
this is my mr georgia basketball plaque
atlanta celtics jersey this is my usa
jersey and this is from um
uh the battle for atlantis when we went
into the bahamas
i got all tournament team just got some
dust on it i really been adding ever
since i got here when i first got here i
didn't have nothing in here then i seen
everybody else from i'm like hold on
they can't
outdo me
you know coach dye
who uh is a legend that we'll never be
able to replace here at auburn
told me he said you know and he's said
it before you can coach him as hard as
you love him
and so i don't love him right away
because i don't know him right away but
i get to know him i am honest with him
and i do hold him accountable if you had
a dad in your life
or an uncle or a grandfather
you put up with him because he he you
know he loved you and he held you to
account didn't he and so i hold him
account
me when i was deciding to come to school
i wanted to come somewhere where i was
going i know i was going to have fun and
i know i was going to build
relationships that would last a lifetime
because auburn just really a family
atmosphere
this small college town
and so kids that come here understand
they're coming here to train they're
coming in to learn
coming here and just wanting to
experience college you know not going
different routes come to school and just
play for a national championship play
for a coach let's coach people like me
he wanted to stay close to home he
wanted his mom and dad to come see him
play he wanted his dad to come into the
gym and train him you know like he had
done you know growing up i got no
problem with guys getting paid when
they're 18 years old if that's what they
want to do go to this league or that
league or whatever
but man they're missing out a lot by not
going to college and just having this
experience
and i'm telling you right now jabari
wouldn't trade this year at auburn for a
lot of money he wouldn't trade it that
money's down the road and he's getting
ready for it
my junior year i remember i just
remember my auburn visit when they
played tennessee
sold out crowd it was loud how free the
players were playing how much fun they
was having how together they were it was
just like why wouldn't you want to play
here why wouldn't you want to play in
that environment
this time fly really i still remember
when i was sitting right there over
there watching
watching the game thinking
dang i want to i want to i want to play
in college i want to play in the sec i
want to play in a game like this just me
being in it now still feel kind of
unreal a little bit saying my name on
the back of the jersey putting on the
uniform every night is just
it still feels kind of fake to me
[Applause]
this team's beating the best teams in
the country
okay
we're going to build our resume in
kentucky and alabama
and gonzaga and baylor and whoever it is
is the best in the country all right we
gotta go through that
we gotta go through them and they gotta
go through us
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
man i want jabari to be one of the best
guys in the community you know i want
him to change so many kids lives i want
him to
be an impact preach being a father a
family man a husband i want that to
continuously come out of his mouth
if you tap into the fact that we're here
to educate young people and get him
ready for what's next that's what i want
for jabari i want to do the best job in
this year to try to prepare him
for what's coming next
that's the goal you know make my family
proud make my dad proud
you know
make it
i feel like i'm on the right track to do
that
you